[Music]
on this Friday night finally headed home
the first group of Hamas hostages and
Israeli prisoners
freed the pause in the fighting and the
essential Aid quickly now moving in the
politics of backing Ukraine the
dwindling support among Canadian
conservatives for the war torn nation is
the season for gift flation it's hard to
say within budget this year our Rising
prices could be pinching holiday
Shoppers and iced out how the NHL is
blocking a goalie from honoring his
wife's indigenous
Heritage Global National with far
Asser cars covered with the
internationally recognized Red Cross
caring what many see as a Beacon of Hope
24 men women and children freed by Hamas
after nearly nearly 7 weeks in
captivity good evening and thanks for
joining us amid High tensions there is a
small sense of relief in the Middle East
tonight as Israel and Hamas completed
the first of what's expected to be a
series of prisoner exchanges of the 24
hostages released 13 were Israeli mainly
elderly women and children ranging in
age from as young as two all the way to
85 years old Tai and Filipino Nationals
also among those freed seen in this
Hamas video
as they were escorted into Red Cross
Vehicles earlier
today this is one of the goals of
Israel's war on Hamas Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu said in a
televised address tonight however he
vowed that Israel would achieve all of
its
goals and in the West Bank cheers rang
out as 39 Palestinian women in te were
released from Israel's offer military
prison just a few of the 300 individuals
who Israel considered for
release this breakthrough is part of a
meticulously negotiated deal that comes
with a 4-day pause in fighting and some
much needed humanitarian Aid being
delivered into Gaza we'll have more on
that in a moment but we begin with Mike
Armstrong and the long awaited exchange
that came after weeks of Relentless
violence and thousands of Civilian
[Music]
deaths the first sightings of the
hostages were on social media videos
shared showing Red Cross Jeeps cheered
as they moved through
Gaza the Convoy crossed into Egypt at
5:53 p.m. local time from there the
hostages moved through Egypt to a border
crossing with Israel where they were
turned over to Israeli teams waiting to
receive
them now among those released the oldest
hostage 85-year-old Rafa ader hello the
two youngest are this man's children
taken by Hamas with their mother October
7th the last news anyone had about them
was this video that's Duran cats Asher
having her head covered the couple's
2-year-old and four-year-old children
are seen hiding their
faces now what wasn't expected was
another group of hostages whose release
wasn't announced in advance According to
cter which worked as a mediator in this
agreement 10 Thai citizens and one
Filipino were also handed over to the
Red Cross they were met in Egypt by
officials from their
embassies there was also cheering for
the prisoners going the other way in
this exchange 39 Palestinians from an
Israeli prison in the West Bank crowds
had gathered on a hill to
watch there were also crowds in the
streets Israel released 24 women and 15
teenage
boys among them Le Offman the
17-year-old was detained earlier this
year on suspicion of throwing an
incendiary
device he says life in the prison was
hard they weren't allowed out of their
cells and he says prisoners were
starving there were emotional moments
for Mara bakir she was arrested at 16
after an altercation with a police
officer after serving 8 years she was
told Friday morning she was being
released says she met people who helped
her in prison but that there's no one
more important than her
mother now the next hours will be
intense the hostages will be reunited
with family but they'll also be
debriefed Israeli teams will try to
collect Intelligence on where the
hostages were being held so as to
perhaps find out where the rest might be
the Israeli military has agreed not to
use drones or aircrafts to monitor Gaza
during this 4-day pause but it still has
satellites and every part of this
Handover was being followed they want to
know where each Hamas fighter came from
and where they went afterwards one
Israeli officer joked confidently today
with an interviewer just between us he
said we'll be watching very closely
Farah Mike Armstrong in Jerusalem thank
you Mike and just before the pause began
the Israeli Defense Forces says it
demolished a Hamas tunnel under the
alifa hospital and other tunnel
entrances in the area this un verified
footage published by the IDF shows the
destruction of the tunnels and what it
says are other Hamas targets since
reaching the hospital the Israeli
military has released numerous videos
showing what it claims is evidence of a
hidden Hamas Command Center underneath
the
hospital the pause has allowed more
desperately needed Aid into Gaza the UN
says 137 trucks came in an Israeli
government agency says it was 200 either
way Aid groups warn weeks of fighting
have left a Chasm so big they won't be
able to meet the needs of the displaced
hungry and wounded in just a few days
Crystal gensing Reports and a warning
some of the images in her story are
distressing the clock is
ticking the pause in fighting is set to
last for 4 days and Aid groups
understand they need to act fast as
lives are at
risk for nearly 7 weeks in Gaza
Palestinians have been struggling in
horrific
conditions conditions so extreme kids
risk jumping onto a moving truck just to
snag some water we proceed on the basis
of the hope and the expectation that we
will reach people in need where they
are um whether that happens obviously I
cannot tell you now
everything from blankets to gas for
cooking is needed in the war torn
Enclave the UN says more than 80% of the
population has been displaced and the
medical system has
collapsed the facilities still open have
too many patients and few supplies even
with the pause in fighting medical staff
didn't get a break the Associated Press
reports two people were fatally shot
Friday and 11 wounded individuals were
rushed to a hospital in southern
Gaza I was returning to the north when
they said there was a truce and they
started shooting at us that is what
happened to me Israeli officials
reportedly dropped letters ahead of the
paus and fighting telling Palestinians
the war was not over they should not try
to return to the north people however
are desperate to go home hoping they say
to find a change of clothes check on
loved ones or honor their dead
there is no life no food we can't find a
loaf of bread we don't know what to do
anymore we feel silly just walking in
the street well some people did try to
head north back to their homes others
went South to safer locations as
instructed by Israeli officials as for
the aid that got into Gaza today un
officials are calling it the biggest
humanitarian Convoy delivery since
October 7th
now for context 4 to 500 trucks used to
make deliveries daily Far crystal ganing
in London thank you Crystal prime
minister Justin Trudeau says a
significant humanitarian pause is
progress but many more steps are needed
for lasting peace in the region
including a two-state solution today
Trudeau was in New Finland and Labrador
at the European Union Summit Canada and
the EU announced a11 billion scientific
research program and Canada also Al
hammered out a deal to build water
bombers and ship them to the
EU As Leaders we're continuing that work
to ensure a future that is safe that has
clean air that has great jobs and where
there is opportunity for
everyone in one place Trudeau also
brought up support for Ukraine as the
war rages on with Democratic Values
under threat around the world the
leaders reaffirmed their commitment to
working together McKenzie gray joins us
now with all the details Mackenzie yeah
for our EU lead and Trudeau are on the
same page about Ukraine but back here in
Ottawa the Canadian political consensus
on supporting keev took its first hit
since the war started Mr Shear Mr mril
that's the entire conservative caucus
voting against updating the Canada
Ukraine Free Trade Agreement on Tuesday
the reason a new chapter on carbon
pricing he did something that has never
been done in the history of trade
agreements which is to put a carbon tax
in one but that's not what the agreement
says it does commit Canada and Ukraine
to promote carbon pricing in measures to
mitigate carbon leakage risks and even
the Ukrainian Embassy in Ottawa says the
New Deal does not compel either country
to implement a fossil fuel Levy but even
if it did Ukraine has had a carbon tax
since
2011 the trade deal still passed its
first parliamentary hurdle without
conservative support but the Prime
Minister believes Pierre POV has an
ulterior motive the rise of a right Wing
American Maga influence
thinking that has made Canadian
conservatives turn their backs on
something Ukraine needs in its hour of
need trudo referencing us Republicans
who want no further Aid to go to Ukraine
today more than 300,000 Ukrainian
Canadians the large Ukrainian community
in Canada first arrived over a 100 years
ago and are now concentrated in
conservative areas nine out of 10 of the
largest Ukrainian diaspora groups live
in Tory ridings but even then support
for keev has been slipping with the
conservative base there is a much higher
segment among conservative voters whose
viewpoint on this is Canada should
should be more likely to stay out of it
another agreement Ukrainian President
Vladimir zalinsky is hoping to ink is
with the European Union and to get that
Ukraine will need to expand their
current carbon tax regime to meet EU
regulations far Mackenzie gray and
Ottawa thank you McKenzie zinski is also
hoping to secure more Aid packages from
the EU and the US Ukraine says Russian
forces are escalating attempts to storm
a strategically important city in
eastern Ukraine and Russia reported
today Ukraine launched a major drone
attack on Crimea it would be the biggest
drone attack on the Russia occupied
territory since the start of Russia's
full-scale Invasion 21 months ago there
was no mention of any casualties or any
damage
Irish police have arrested at least 34
people in response to rioting after five
people were stabbed in Dublin yesterday
the Justice Minister says the most Riot
police in the country's history were
deployed Vehicles were tored shops were
looted and crowds through rocks a huge
cleanups now underway police blame farri
protesters for the
unrest Michael Cong is speaking out
against allegations by Michael spavor
that c and the Canadian government had
manipulated spavor leading to the pair's
three-year detainment in China in a
statement C says he was never involved
in Espionage activities and that quote
any insinuation that I was anything but
open and honorable in my interactions
with Michael spavor is false spavor is
now seeking a multi-million dollar
settlement with the federal government
Deal or No Deal how inflation is
impacting holiday gift budgets coming up
it's not shop till you drop this Black
Friday
[Music]
Black Friday Shoppers Brave the cold
early this morning outside the Mall of
America in Minnesota to get take
advantage of this season's biggest deals
on this side of the border the lineups
were more muted as Nita ganguli explains
despite the deep discounts many
Canadians are weighing the choice of
spending or saving on this year's gifts
it's the biggest shopping event of the
Year black frate actually planning for
it starts many many months before the
actual weekend but High inflation has
83% of Canadians expecting holiday gifts
to cost them more this year says Roshan
Jinger from Financial Services firm
Square Canadians are really bracing for
this thing that we're calling gift
flation Black Friday discount started
earlier than ever this year in an effort
to attract customers according to Marty
win trob everyone's washingt to to grab
that consumer especially this season so
the sooner they can get out there and
get those deals in front of consumers
the better shop retailers say they have
a capture the wallet there used to be
lots of lineups but uh now we're finding
that a lot of customers are shopping
early they're shopping online one in
three Canadians plans to start their
holiday shopping in November according
to deit survey with 11% saying they will
complete all their shopping between
Black Friday and Cyber Monday with
Canadians shelling out more for food
shelter and other Essentials deoe
expects holiday spending will fall 11%
compared to last year it's not really
something we're focused on the economy
in general is just hard to manage as a
university student on the other hand
Ginger says many Shoppers will actually
stretch their budgets to give their
loved ones the best gifts that they can
about half of them are going to up their
budget and they're going to up their
budget about 20% so that to me indicates
that folks still value the importance of
gift giving and celebrating the holiday
season but overspending is a serious
concern one that could persist long
after the holidays you know household
debt levels in Canada have been rising
and you know what we don't want to have
is that surprise freddit card statement
oh when we open up the bills come
January Nita Gangi Global News
Toronto ah had how a BC indigenous
Community is taking on an oil giant over
a $35 billion pipeline Expansion Project
[Music]
some members of a BC indigenous
Community are voicing their opposition
to the Trans Mountain pipeline
expansion's new route through a sacred
site those against the move say they
won't back down and as Nea reports it
sparked doubt in other communities over
agreements already
signed the Little Creek over here we
have uh Co salmon we have Cutthroat and
rainbow trout people don't realize how
much life is sustained by a little creek
like that the richness of these
ancestral homelands summa's First Nation
Chief Dalton silver says is precious and
needs to be protected it's why he's
conflicted over the agreement his Nation
about an hour east of Vancouver has
signed with Trans Mountain it goes
against my I guess my gut feeling he
says in early November a salmon bearing
stream was affected as workers were
Drilling in the territory Trans Mountain
confirms 54 fish in a slew in his
territory died this week after Crews
evacuated a site turning off a water
pump following an avien flu scare the
company is investigating the incident
and says it's complying with all
regulatory requirements they came too
close to the bottom of the Waterway and
it collapsed that same week Trans
Mountain was ordered to stop pipeline
work over environmental infractions in
one of the nation 's Wetland areas Chief
silver says he worries about his
nation's ability to monitor the
company's compliance in protecting the
land and sacred indigenous sites staff
that are closely monitoring things as as
much as we can right but like of a lot
of other places I think we short staffed
we've seen the desecration of so many
sacred places and our people in general
are really looking I think to to
maintain identity and maintain the
cultural ways a sacred site in BC's
inter I called pip cell at Jacko lake is
a source of controversy it is in our
territory on unseated territory unseated
land it's our
territory uh that uh nobody goes around
it and disturbs it Canada's energy
regulator recently ruled in favor of
Trans Mountain to revise its pipeline
route and dig an open trench here
despite opposition from community
members like Carolyn Henry they just
walk all over you and expect you to take
it and we're not going to take it we
will not back down ourselves through our
own territory now looking back at this
proposal in this pipeline it's going to
looked strange that it just was pushed
through against people's opposition we
actually um negotiated a a relationship
agreement that was unique and that I
don't think there were any other First
Nations that had that Chief silver says
terms in his nation's agreement with
Trans Mountain give him some comfort
over his concerns we can have all the
money in the world but if uh if the
resources are all destroyed around us if
if we're in a place that the livability
is actually in question well where do we
go as he's constantly questioning
whether it's a risk worth taking Nea
Global News Sumas First
Nation the Minnesota Wild is celebrating
Native American Heritage night at its
game this evening but the NHL has
quashed how a goalie plan to embrace the
idea Mark Andre flurry who plays for the
wilds and is from Quebec had a custom
mask painted to honor his wife and her
family's indigenous Heritage the NHL
however has threatened to find flurry
and the team if he wears it during
tonight's game or even during the
[Music]
warm-up next how a Canadian company is
embracing artificial intelligence in the
[Music]
workplace
artificial intelligence is just about
everywhere from our smartphones to our
home assistants and Canada ranks in the
top five countries for research and
development this week on the new reality
Mike drle looks at how our Workforce is
getting an overhaul while Federal
Regulations leg
behind Air Canada like so many other
companies finds itself at a Crossroads
keep doing what they're doing and let
the competition pass pass them by or
Embrace how artificial intelligence can
transform
everything AI is here whether we like it
or not Bruce Stam has been charged with
getting the ball rolling last month
there Canada started using an AI powered
program to set its schedules next year
AI will be used to streamline
maintenance schedules which Stam says
will make the company more efficient and
profitable and we never take the human
out of the loop in terms of decision
making none of the systems that we have
built to actually remove somebody it's
more giving them the ability to look at
numerous predations and combinations and
that otherwise would take hours to do AI
often gets a bad rap but not all AI
programs are created equal shall we play
a game deep learning AI is what you see
in most Hollywood movies I'm sorry Dave
I'm afraid I can't do that and yes that
can be terrifying but where Canada set
itself apart is with machine learning AI
which only works with human input by
most metrics Canada is a top five AI
country for research and
development AI is a transformative
technology that is going to make World a
much better place and help us solve some
of the most pressing challenges as a
society that we face right now where the
AI World falls short is in regulation
Canada won't see laws in place until
2025 at the earliest until then there's
a volunt code of conduct for the
industry there's an acknowledgement we
need to deal with the concerns and the
risks so that we can realize the
opportunities a and in order to do that
uh we need framework we need guard Wills
so we build trust with people AI it is
said will change the world in ways never
seen before and Canada has a front row
seat fasten your seat belts Mike jle
Global News
Toronto Mike speaks with some of the
Canadian leaders in Ai and looks at the
Innovations coming soon that's Saturday
at 7:00 p.m. on the new reality and
that's global national for this Friday
night I'm far ner and tonight's your
Canada is Nathan Phillips Square in
downtown Toronto until tomorrow take
care of yourselves and take care of each
other good
[Music]
night